you
[Music]
morning everyone so I'm Ethan from a
connectivity team together with licious
from Hadoop platform team at Weber so
we've been working together closely on
bridging the gaps for the near real-time
pipelines today we'll be talking about
how we power
boobers global and our analytics in near
real-time with apache hudie data
streamer so for the agenda of this talk
we first talk about the problem we face
and why we need this real-time pipeline
to serve the requirements then an issues
we'll talk about the background of
Apache who the incremental boost and how
these can support our requirements and
next I will talk about the details of
building the incremental pipelines and
then some experience that will burn off
shipping these pipelines in production
so as you may already know our ubers
mission is to ignite the opportunity by
setting the world in motion so the
company operates in more than 600 cities
across 64 countries on six continents so
we have achieved 10 billion punitive
chips so Ober is a mobile first company
this means that most our users access
our services purely through our mobile
apps including the driver rider and each
app so this means that our apps rely
100% on wireless networks including
Wi-Fi and cellular so in fact as you can
see here most our network traffic is
coming through several networks for
example 92% of traffic is from the
driver app using LTE 2g and 3G so since
user expects real-time performance we
must ensure that the ABS are performant
and we need to provide near real-time
visibility into the network reliability
and performance so that we can observe
any outage regressions or performance
issues properly so well this seems to be
a very straightforward it is challenging
for us because well as never performance
is highly variable so as you can see
here on this slide
it shows the tail and latency tail and
narrow latency across the major cities
we operate so we highly varies across
different cities and even mega regions
also there are other dimensions that can
also affect the network performance to
give you some examples so overtime like
different days a week from Monday to
Thursday as you can see on this slide
the performance actually varies so this
can be due to different level different
levels of network load and congestion
and besides even across different mobile
carriers you can see on the bottom a
figure on this slide it shows the
performance of two major carriers in
Delhi India so you can clearly see that
right one is clearly worse than the left
one so because of the coverage they
provide and the technology they use so
in general we observe more than 4000
mobile carriers used by our drivers and
Driver partners and riders so finally
there are other dimensions that also
affect the performance to name a few
like the protocols we use a different
version of HTTP like the domain names we
send the traffic through and the user
mobility so the meta point here is that
the Nano performance varies across a
number of dimensions and the cardinality
is very huge so to provide these
visibility into the variable level
performance we identify three challenges
of holies
holy CR never monitoring at scale so we
start with using the elks tag which
provide these real-time diagnose
diagnose into the different dimensions
like you can drill down into different
countries cities and even our types
however there's one three challenges we
face when using this stack so the first
is that we need the breakdowns into the
different dimensions I just mentioned
and the Canada Cardinal is huge and to
give you some numbers is on the order of
10 minions the second is that we see
I'll actually do some sampling and we
also need to I also like because the
data source for when our Brown events
are huge like other billions of records
per day so that incurs the challenges of
civic scaling this resolution app the
third is that we need some custom
transformations to calculate the metrics
we monitored so we start to complement
these Elks that we use these common
lambda architecture by adding one more
or batch processing pipelines so we we
basically write a difference by
pipelines to generate performance
summaries in the hive tables and we
visualize these data are into the
dashboard like the figures show on this
slide we have like limbo requests the
error rates and for example latency
across different countries as you can
see here so we monitored these different
metrics or through the pipeline's and
you go back so basically this allows the
uncle engineers to just look at this
dashboard if there's any outage where
issues with just a few clicks in a few
minutes
instead of writing hive queries with
custom filters and transformations and
waiting for the result in in a few hours
so this actually enables good experience
for the unco engineer's so to give you
some details about how we use this
legacy badge pipeline so our source
table is in hive and the data is
partitioned by date and we directly
write to another summary table and as
you can see here each dimension
breakdown each day a week we have a
record for showing the performance and
whenever there's new data for the day
comes we load the entire day what we
cost weeks of data to transform them
into the actual metrics in the hive
table so these poses are fewer
scalability challenges and in our case
the first is that basically whenever in
the late time of the day were late I
mother
ladies are in the week we have to read
the same data repeatedly that has really
be processed in the previous rest so
these incurs expensive table scan the
second is that sense we read this data
repeatly we need to reprocess them and
recompute the metrics again and again so
these also basically in terms of the
computers where this is also inefficient
finally when we generate of this
conference summary we need to scratch
the whole partitions in the day and a
week and then we need to refresh over at
the table with those entries so that
makes the overall refresh ness of the
data less so in our experiments it takes
around three to four hours to finish run
run and don't get that they are freshly
done into the table so I'm more in
conceptually a more efficient way to
generate these summaries whenever
there's some new data as shown here in
the blue box we just read them each in
each time so we don't have to scan them
periodically and then we transform them
into some deltas summary and then only
update the summary data be changed so
this way basically we we are able to in
curl this table scan under the dealer's
website and we can have a more efficient
computation at the end we don't have to
scratch the whole destination partition
and we only need to update the Y's that
has been changed so we started
handoff to Nicias to talk about how who
di incremental pool primitives enable
these kind of pipeline concepts right
thanks Ethan
so as Ethan mentioned this work is
actually in collaboration with the two
teams so I work on the Hadoop platform
team I'll spend some time introducing
hoodie and then we look at the scale at
which it's used at uber and then finally
we will understand how incremental pull
helps power the network by plans that it
has got to talk about right so hoodie is
essentially a library that can basically
used
turn bad jobs into incremental jobs
hurry does this by incorporating these
concepts of deltas using which you can
scale more by avoiding recomputed
recomputation x' of unnecessary parts of
the data so think of hoodie as a spark
library which can be used to do
mutations to datasets it can manage your
files efficiently and then it can
provide different views on this data it
does all of this by using primitives and
we call them as absurd insert and
incremental pull primitives so if you
look at the illustration on the right
side there's a bunch of change locks
which may be for example database change
locks that you want to ingest and with
the with the absurd primitive provided
by hoodie you could actually write these
data sets out as three data sets on your
favorite cloud data store and then you
can essentially query these data sets
using your favorite query engine be it
hype rest or spark and finally if you
wanted to know exactly what happened to
these data sets you can actually also
consume change locks in an incremental
fashion using the incremental pull
primitives provided by three so sorry
yeah and what is open source please feel
free to go to the github link and the
documentation link and active on the
mailing list it's it's a budding project
would love to see questions around that
so let's look at an alternate hoody
based architecture which is actually
what we use it over so there's a bunch
of changelogs as I said which are which
we want to ingest say we push these
change logs into a message bus like
Kafka using hoodies incremental and
absurd primitives you can actually store
and ingest these data sets into your
favorite cloud near a lake or HDFS which
is used it over in about five minutes
freshness and so when you ingest this as
these this data as three data sets it
will do the complete file management for
you file sizing for you managing like
what is the file count for your data
sets finally how do you will expose
three different types of views which can
be used to query this data set one view
is the base column not performance view
which is which we call read optimize so
if you wrote your data set out as
parking then
you get part every performance the
real-time view is something that lets
you get really faster freshness by
merging two different file formats which
rewrite which is parky and I'll go right
now and finally the incremental
primitive can be used to incremental
e-poll what happened and build for the
downstream data flows so the one thing
that hoodie does for us is it eliminates
the need for specialized DB so if you
think about certain use cases like ml
dashboarding a lot of these use cases
fall in the in the realm of about 5
minutes 10 minutes latency so instead of
having to special to different systems
especially ideal ways for something and
a cloud datastore for storing large
amounts of data we try to bridge this
gap and reduce operational overhead all
right so let's look at like what scale
hood is used it over so 3 is used to
manage about tens of petabytes of data
on the Hruby relic
that's that equals to about the
thousands of pipelines and tables which
are ingesting hundreds of terabytes of
data per day so so now that we know a
little bit about hoody let's just talk
about the incremental model and so for D
helps unlocks T stream style processing
on bash data so if you were to draw a
spectrum of you know different latency
is provided by different technologies
daily basis generally lie in the realm
of you know less than one second you can
observe data you can query your data and
latency czar of that sort and then batch
data it tends to be of the order of the
hours and stream processing lies
somewhere between like you know a few
seconds to a few minutes and what we're
suggesting is like you know with hoody
and many jobs using incremental and
absurd primitives you can achieve near
real-time which lies between 5 minutes
to 1 hour depending on how aggressively
you aggressively you run your data set
so the two popular primitives that are
used to do this are absurd which is
basically you can ingest this and modify
the results that you wrote
think of it as a state store in a stream
processing system an incremental pool
which basically can be used to stream
the changes that happen to this data set
and then build better
downstream data flows and that's it
what we do with our instrumental
pipelines so basically think of you know
a bunch of updates happening to a
dataset and they're basically touching a
lot of so say your dataset is written
out as files and they're starting
touching a lot of files so they're at
the end of the day you want to
incremental e pull these the changes
that exactly happen does it on this data
set and that's what the hood incremental
pull lets you do and lets you pull
exactly what got updated and then you
can actually use this to write
downstream data sets which are maybe
hurry or power your dashboard directly
and so so this is the the incremental
feature which we'll get into and talk
about how that powers the network
analytics pipelines so finally I'll go
over some popular ways to use hoodie so
one of the popular ways is to use this
partly resource API to read and write or
do data sets so it's as simple as if you
have a use part it's that simple as
writing your spark tag by just providing
the format the way I've pointed out here
and then you can just like read your
data set as a data frame and then write
it out using this part tag and the other
way which is also very popular way which
is the focus of this talk is the hoodie
Delta streamer think of it as a mini
ingestion framework that has
configurable sources sinks and schemer
repositories and has built-in support
for hoodie so if you look at the
documentation online there's a very
simple way to start using this which is
basically through a spot submit command
you provide this env class and you say
hey what is this source what is your
sink and what operation do you want to
do on this data set for example observe
and essentially once you start doing
this you can ingest your data at
5-minute freshness depending on how
aggressive you run it doing up search on
the data set so I'll hand it back over
to Ethan to talk about how these
incremental pull is helping achieve
better optimization on our networks
analytics pipelines okay thanks Alisha's
for introducing the hoodie part so now I
will talk about the details of how we
view these incremental pipelines
leveraging who these are primitives so
let's recap on the general pipe
architecture so basically we need to
reaffirm the incremental data and then
generate some Delta results and merge
them into the final summary table so two
parts has been already solved by Hudy
which is the incremental pose I absurd
so there's one more component we need to
figure which is how we computed the
other results in terms of our metrics so
you know our pipelines we generate three
types of metrics so the first is the
count for example the number of network
costs and the average samples the second
is the ratio of percentage like HTTP
level ever read like the number of
percent above traffic specific version
of HTTP and the third is that we
monitored the percentiles of request
division like P 50 P 95 and P 99 so the
requirements of incrementally update
these traffic that we need to only use
the incremental data and we somehow need
to only use some amount of intermediate
results and these results that must be
as small as possible so that you can
enable fast transformation so then we
use these process called sketching so
sketching is no more than just
generating the multiple summary so for
example you want to generate the
accounts for the from the other data
then you can generate accounts for each
incremental parts and then you aggregate
what you sum up all the counts together
together over all accounts for the whole
data so sketching means that you
generates model use modular structure to
generate a mirja basalt and that can be
used to calculate will approximate the
metrics and next we will talk about how
we design appropriate algorithms for all
categories of these metrics to enable
incremental update so for the count and
re-show metrics is relatively simple
because it's additive so as well as I
explained for counts you only need to
calculate the counts for each
incrementals and the algorithm together
at the final stage for the ratio or
percentage metric similarly we represent
them in two to two numbers why is the
denominator the other is the numerator
so restoring the accounts for both of
these count these numbers and the idea
we want to calculate overall ratio or a
percentage we calculated by the sum of
the numerator divided by the sum of
denominator so example here is that we
have two different data then we stored
counts of numerator and in order like
one and ten for the left three and 20
for the right then when you come up with
the overall ratio only to sum up the
both parts like 4 and 30 and then you
get a ratio of 0.13 so compared to the
count and visual metrics the percentile
metrics are difficult relatively
difficult to a sketch because that is
non additive so you cannot just simply
store the p50 p95 and p9 and and just
add them it simply doesn't work so we
need some way to sketch the
distributions of the raw data so that's
why we use a data structure called he
digest so what is what is to digest so
teenagers is special data structure
formed by clustering the real real value
of our samples with variable size bins
so to give you an example here so we
have a lot of raw data points shown on
the x axis and y axis the quantiles so
instead of showing all the raw points we
can interpolate the distribution by just
four line segments and each line
represents different numbers of samples
X as you can see here so instead of
storing all the samples you only need to
store four bins so that can still
represent a relatively well of the
original distribution as you can see
here both line segments and Brau points
are pretty much fit together
so this data structure actually gives
high accuracy near the tail of the even
near that here of the distribution so
what we can do is for each for each
incremental we come up with this tea
digest data structure to sketch the
distribution at the end when we want to
come up with the overall percentiles we
first merge all that he dirty digest
together
into still into the variable size beans
and I come out with the quantiles so
another good property of the tea digest
data structure is that when you merge
the rejected address of different
distribution of different ranges you can
still guarantee there's no loss in
accuracy so that's actually good for our
case we don't last too much accuracy
when merging the tea digest and one more
good thing about these data structure is
that you can also tune the trade-off
between accuracy and storage footprint
so you can control the nega data you
store for these sketches alright so
since we talked about all all the
techniques how of how to sketch the
different types of metrics I like to
talk about how we leverage these
schedules to generate the summary so we
we create a separate Apache hive table
to store the different sketches like
counts ratio to digest so that we can
always use it later instead of reading
the route table repeatedly
so we once we have the incremental wrong
events we update the sketches
incrementally and since the tea that
just uses some special data structure in
memory we see realizes into the string
so that it can be stored so once we have
the updated data sketches we generate a
performance summary just based on the
new sketches or updated schedules so
that we don't have to scratch all the
destination table so here is how we
construct a pipeline in production so we
have three tables all the tables are in
foody format try to basically leveraging
the primitives of incremental pools and
absurds
so we have raw event table and sketch
table and summary table so we have two
jobs
to finish the finish updating the
performance summary first stage is the
sketching basically generating from the
wrong events to the sketches second
stage is we generate the summary from
the updated sketches so
full flow is that weary from the
incremental data generated Delta
sketches and merge them into the sketch
table and finally based on the new and
updated sketches generating the Delta
summary we merge this the other summary
into the final performance my table so
let me talk a little bit about some
details of how we implement this
pipeline with foodie data streamer so in
terms of the transforming the
incrementals into the data results we
use the hoodie transformer interface so
this interface allows us to pre-process
and filter the raw events and then
transform them to the desired results we
want so these correspond to the these
diagram so in order to observe these
Delta's into the final table we use
another interface called
for the pelo interface so this interface
has a specific function to allow us to
update the sketches or summaries with
the same key like the same dimension
breakdowns so that we can update the
entries in the destination table alright
so that's how we construct a pipeline so
let me talk about talk about some
experiments which about which how we
ship these up incremental pipelines in
production so we have four steps in
terms of the production setup so we
first need to test these jobs to make
sure that there's no problem so we use
the sparks emit comment and store the
Apache hoodie configs into the poverties
file in height so that for example we
need to know the source table partition
path designated destination table etc so
in this way these conflicts can be
passing to that the other streamer class
were running the job and to monitor
these pipelines we have we use the other
box hoody matrix and which is emitted to
the graph on a dashboard so we have
metrics like total duration of
transformation plus commit time like the
absolute time we have the number of new
files added we have the number of
added or updated so in this way we can
compare the performance of this pipeline
with the legacy batch processing
pipeline so after that we found a few
improvements that we can do in terms of
hoody and the pipeline so two specific
thing I'd like to talk about is first we
found that further pushing down the
predicates and projection pruning to
hoody side have further improved the
table scan time so it has like two to
three times improvements and I'm reading
the data this is because the our
pipeline we do a lot of filtering and
basically transformations in our
pipeline said we don't always use other
Network events the second is that since
we are now reading the whole date
partition we are only reading the
incrementals we basically scaled down
the shop number of shuffle partitions
inspark
so in this way the pipeline is more
efficient so after that we deployed this
pipeline to our Hadoop young cluster
using Apache discipline so if you are
now familiar with Apache sibling it is a
web-based notebook that can allow
basically data analytics and interactive
and understanding of the data and he
supports spark and Hadoop OtterBox so we
use it to deploy our pipeline and we set
up the chrome tab in Devlin to basically
let these pipelines to run every hour
and before we talk about the performance
of this pipeline we also need to
understand that the result generate by
this pipeline are actually valid
so we run incremental and batch jobs in
parallel for about one to two weeks so
we compare the performance metrics
generated by both pipelines and what we
found is that for the calibration metric
the exactly match and for the personnel
metrics the everyway is less than 0.5
percent for large dimension breakdowns
like which has more than 10k samples so
let's talk about the performance of the
pipeline
so to give you some idea of the data
size as I already mentioned we have
billions of records each day of the
route network events uploaded from the
mobile site and these translate to
several hundreds of gigabytes of data
per day so for the regarding the batch
update pipeline we configure around 1
1200 course for it and the run time is
around 3 to 4 hours and it takes around
10 to 20 minutes on table scan alone and
more than 1200 hours an actual
computation so if you look at the
spectrum of the drop run time where the
latest requirement are shown by the
licious slide before basically the patch
is on the right side right hand side so
to compare with that for incremental
pipelines we only configure around 100
have 50 course because it doesn't
require much computation so for the
schedule stage II thought it takes like
30 to 40 minutes to finish only 6
minutes
and reset about half over on a
computational right and similarly for
the summary stage since the sketch is
very very small the total stage the
stage of runtime is smaller than 30
minutes and he's only 2 minutes to read
the data basically the sketches and then
takes around 20 minutes to generate the
performance summary and write it to the
destination table so basically if you
look at the spectrum the near real-time
pipeline by from this incremental sits
between the stream and batch busy
pushing the batch towards the left side
to be less than one hour so overall we
see that these the improvements on the
computer is vs. 8 times and we also see
that for both the read and compute side
the improvements is more than three
times over this leads to around four
times under freshness of the data so
this really shows how we can leverage
the full potentials of who these
primitives to build is any real time
pipeline so that's all we have with that
we are interesting our work feel free to
drop an email here and we are also
having and that's all we have
thanks for listening and we are we'd
love to take any questions now hi thanks
for the talk so you have said that
hoodie internally manages upsets and
everything internally without we need to
do any of the thing is it only on the
HDFS or if you use any cloud storage
like s3 out plops to still it works like
that yeah so we've we've used it with
multiple so there are consumers so
internally at uber we use HDFS but
consumers outside using hoodie they've
used it against eg css3 it works for
those cloud data stores if there's
another cloud datastore it should work
so how internally it manages for upsets
and anything so it's anything wrapper
like on top of Parque formatting manages
something like to manage the updates and
yeah so it's a storage abstraction in
the storage format right now for example
for columnar it's a poor Sparky and it's
just an abstraction over part K it
manages tagging updates where the
updates are supposed to go it has two
different types of table types
copy-on-write and margin read depending
on what support performance you want so
it's a storage abstraction on type of
already provide formats so if we if that
is the case do we need to use the same
finally if I write it as a 4k format and
then I want to read it from any other
different tool which doesn't understand
I put hoodie still it can use to read
the same file a say yeah you can so so
the reader part is exhausting about
hoodie so you can basically there's a
there's there's an input format that
sits in the middle which is basically
how every presto - saturated you just
register that and your queries or on
file as they used to thank you
is hoody able to preserve the ordering
of the absurds yes so if you are
incremental pulling it it will give you
what happened say between T 1 and T 2
and then T 3 T 4 and then so on about
things that happen at the same time
stamp yeah so it ingests data in batches
so if if all the records happen during
the same time they'll then if you
incremental e pull them all of them will
will basically be tail to you so I don't
know if I understand the question
correctly are you saying updates are
ordered or do you incremental pull and
are they're ordered I'm wondering so in
coffee you have to partition on a
partition key to maintain the ordering
and I'm wondering if who deep reserves
that partitioning on the key so the data
is written out on to a partitioned data
set and then depending on the time stamp
who do you is gonna give you batches in
ordered fashion we can take it off
Hey so it seems like the merge strategy
part of it is really kind of complicated
and undefined like for example that the
t-distribution thing like I had no idea
what that was about but like how do you
come up with that you have to just kind
of be thoughtful about the way you
increment you're like you distribute out
your pipeline so that the increments can
kind of be merged after that or like
like the merge strategy aspect of it yes
so so in terms of their merging
basically when each incremental comes so
to start with maybe from the let's talk
about the first day stage so for we
store some sketches right so for the
destination table of this sketch table
we store the daily level of aggregates
say like the data as 24 batches
yeah they each one one patch comes in we
calculate like the outer counts like the
ratios and tea digest and then we store
them merge them into the table so these
cash table always keeps basically up to
date and then whenever new data comes to
merge them into this table and then the
summary table only needs to depend on
the sched table for the final summary
performing summaries not sure if that
answers so just to add to that out of
the box wholly supports multiple mode
strategies for example overwrite latest
so if you have the same row key for
example and you just want to overwrite
it that's out of the box if you want to
simply merge something for example
credence timestamp that's out of the box
but you have two different payloads
which the same row can you want to do
something with it which is where we're
doing something right here then you need
to define your own mode strategy and
plug in that analysis work box
so I love the idea of you know what you
call stream like near real-time
processing I love the idea of doing
batch processing continuously I'm just
curious what the bottlenecks are that
prevent your latency from going even
lower so not that you should fix them
but what are the bottlenecks that ensure
that you know there's like a 10 minute
latency to this process is it that
you're doing a you know building a hash
table or or or what and if so you know
what could you potentially change not in
hoody but in your in your system to get
the latency lower thanks for the
question yeah so the the main bottleneck
is the file format that you write data
into so you write large party files
because that's very good for how queries
work how our specific name Lord works in
HDFS so we write about 512 to 1gb party
files so the larger part I finally write
the longer it takes to write there's
party files so that's the main water
line
there is also an indexing border length
so because all of this has to be indexed
inside the data set so Kody has three
different components which is like
storage indexing and data and so the
indexing component sometimes can take
longer time depending on the high
cardinality but that that's something
that we've reduced the main bottleneck
is party writing which is basically any
data format that you choose that is
another so as I talked about really
support student ID of tables copyright
and Mojo nary in the Morgan Rielly you
actually can write avro which is much
faster because it's it compresses
differently that using that you can
actually achieve maybe like a couple of
minutes three minutes latency but beyond
that then it's just like how how much
time it takes to read a batch how much
time it takes to write a batch may be a
little bit of processing so yeah
[Music]